[Musica]
bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono opachi j
oggi siamo su un videogame che a mio
parere è alquanto demenziale ovvero
cookie ma va allora ragazzo mi chiedete
come mi è venuto in mente di fare una
serie su cooking mama perché non ne ho
idea
a volte mi escono state e pazze però
diciamo che ho pensato potesse essere
divertente da vedere anche da giocare
spero se non manda a fuoco tutto se vi
piacerà lo porterò avanti di sicuro e va
beh direi di iniziare allora vediamo
come cosa diavolo b combino in cucina
cuciniamo amici e cibo del mondo amici e
cibo e opzioni ok direi di andare sul
cuciniamo vediamo ed iniziare subito a
far casino allora abbiamo le ricette di
tutto il mondo direi di andare su italia
pizza spaghetti e mandolino a via vai
ok vai li faccio un piatto di maccheroni
tieni telecomando wii in verticale
questo è il mio telecomando wii direi di
avviare vediamo se riesco a giocarci con
l'emulatore per confrontasi know cos'è
oh mio dio devo più una scatola vai mio
secondo nome apriscatole mi chiamano
anche così vai così se ce l'ha fatta
ho aperto la scatola ye sono un cuoco
nato ebbene se è normale vai così grazie
mille sposta il cursore del pelapatate
verso gli ingredienti e muovere
dall'alto in basso per sbucciare gli
ingredienti vai così vediamo le patate
che cazzo
beh guarda sono un pelapatate umano sono
nato pelapatate cazzo
che cosa stupida va bene ci si sono sono
un fenomeno in cucina benedetta parodi
non è un cazzo in confronto a me vai
cos'è ma che cazzo olè olè olè operato
un anno ancora madonna quanta roba da
pelare ok mi sento un cocconato certo
che a pelare le patate la mia vocazione
da bambino sognavo di farlo
dai che ce la devo fare maledizione sta
scadendo il tempo ma cazzo non cipiglio
mai così caldo sta scadendo il tempo
cioè pian seri quando gioca che mario
porca [ __ ] se ce l'ho fatta
basta ancora ancora anno perfetto finito
se ce l'ho fatta a voto molto bene
grande meglio di mamma ebe certo quali
già è meglio di mamma grazie a cazzo è
devo trita finalmente ok
devo tritare devo trattare la roba ok
vai così a tritiamo le patate vice e
rega devo aprire un ristorante ca zzo fa
vj and company vice compilando ok carota
vai devo tagliare la carota guardate che
taglio preciso con la spada manco inu
yasha taglia così precisamente vai così
mio dio perfetto ok il mio dio
minuziano ci siamo dai cazzo se ce l'ho
fatta
ci parlo anche la cipolla no che cazzo
vien da piangere vista vendendola
piangere lo stesso anche se non ce l'ho
qui davanti veramente mai fagiolini oh
mio dio da sminuzzare di tutto
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
vedere la madonna santissima pazzo è più
stancante che fare jogging porca [ __ ]
se molto bene cazzo devo partecipare
alle gare internazionali di cucina le
vinco cotte ok ragazzi manca l'ultima
crisi in olio bollente ce la posso fare
posso fare un minestrone che manco
ratatouille il cibo di uscire vai così
allora mettiamo prima ok come devo fare
un mio addio
non ho idea mettiamo prima la patata a
caso ma c'è un ordine cazzo mi sto
mettendo tutta vabbè andiamo così chi se
ne fotte vai rosoliamo o che la patata è
andata finalmente vai così se si stanno
processo mio dio ce la sto facendo
beh devo andare avanti quanto cazzo devo
girare non lo so sto cucinando a caso
ebbene sì devo andare avanti ancora si
vai così vai vai vai vai vai lì manca
uno è finito
non ci credo non ci posso credere che
sono riuscito beh sì so io ho buttato in
mezzo ho buttato nella padella di tutto
a caso senza motivo e sono riuscito se
un piatto all'italiana cazzo ce la posso
fare
watch in umido che hai ragazzo vorrebbe
essere l'ultima questa è anche devo devo
girare la roba cosa devo fare aiuto
devo ad unire devono premere a tempo a
siti pochi tahrir o soltanto che non è
proprio guitar hero medio cosa vuol dire
vai cosa vuol dire cosa non fare io mi
state smistate cosa devo fare
a devo girare ma [ __ ] che ne so io
vai vai vai così vai così fai così alto
alto cosa questo devo fare di alto ok ok
vai vai vai vai no ma non cipiglio
punitiva e pomodori scazzi grande grande
come faccio girare impossibile a ok ma
che ne so io io e verrà una merda ho
fatto bene tutto il resto ma verrà una
merda poi vabbè lasciamo perdere
unisci vai sono pronto sono pronto se i
fagiolini a il tempo giusto ce la posso
fare
quanto preso ti prego dimmi almeno un
bene di me almeno un bene c'è ho preso
ce l'ho fatta raga va bene così mi
accontento
buon appetito a tutti adesso velo
serviranno in tavola fatemi sapere se
non vomitate sulla tastiera in tal caso
il traguardo hai una nuova ricetta
perfetto raga posso cucinare dell'altro
il primo piatto l'italiano è andato bene
giustamente adesso dire di provare col
giapponese andiamo con sushi
non so se c'è il sushi a rho e mochi
cos'è mochi non lo so non ho mai sentito
nominare scusate la mia ignoranza ma ci
proviamo lo stesso forse del riso si
devo schiacciare cosa vuol dire vai vai
nuovi il telecomando ok come cazzo
faccio
[Musica]
ma che cazzo è successo ma cosa ho fatto
ma dai ma dai lavava bela l'abbiamo come
cazzo
ok siamo partiti di merda non importa
finirà bene lo so devo mescolare vai
sono un mescolato romano la prossima
volta ti fico anche in lavatrice come
cazzo si gira o mio dio
ebbene mi sento un idiota vai gira con
l'edizione vai vai vai deve avere mai
dai sta scadendo il tempo cazzo ce la
puoi fare
manca poco no cazzo cielo quasi prima di
aver appreso almeno bene no cazzo raga i
piatti giapponesi mi vengono di merda
poi bollire il riso va bene stato tutto
il resto andata una merda quindi
proviamoci lo stesso vai facciamo
bollire che devo fare qui devo che
cacciano fare
datemi una mano cosa devo fare ai 8
vista sono fare qua si sta bruciando
raga si sta bruciando tutto ho finito ma
cosa devo fare
ho capito ma impegnati cosa cosa dovevo
fare
ho fatto cioè vabbè ragano capita questa
festa al mochi ma sì tanto andato a
[ __ ] quindi lo portiamo anche con le
scarpe a sto punto devo a cazzo cos'è mi
devo amici che mi son beccato la mano ok
ed evo pestarlo quando non c'è la mano
che è perfetto vai vai così vai così
sono un pescatore umano vai così devo
fare cazzo no chi starà odiando questo è
bene vai vai così ce la possiamo fare me
lo sento
me lo sento prendiamo via no
raga niente ho pensato di più la mano
che l'impasto ma non importa vai ce la
possa ancora fare
credo in me stesso se vai così prendi
velocità c'è cazzo che far casa
fantastica se guardate che macchina
guardate che macchina lavoratrice
madonna mia santa socio preso il ritmo
vai vai vai
ce la posso fare se cazzo ce l'ha fatta
è un miracolo schiacciato duemila volte
la mano del tizio ma ce l'ho fatta
ugualmente si grattugia va bene
grattugiamo non ho idea di che cosa da
fare qui dove gratuite vai così vai sono
un grattugiato re umano è cosa devo fare
qui vai così madonna mia santa marta
capace che in realtà non riesco neanche
a farlo così vai così vai vai vai fatto
se ce l'ho fatta molto bene te alla
faccia dei file iniziali
ok prepara qualche moto ok alla fine
vero speriamo
vai così mi sento pronto devo cosa devo
fare qui dopo mescolare ok vai
sono pronto ma è così mai così
grandissimo cos'è chi ci sta cagando un
piccione dentro cosa devo fare devo
girare o mio dio è mai più di così come
lo devo girare cazzo
ok vai ce l'ho fatta credo ancora ma
cazzo sono mi sta venendo il mal di
testa
devo farne 5 così ok ragazzi sono siamo
anche a quello dopo cosa devo fare un
impastarli vai mio zio cosa stupida
devo ancora si vai così vai cos'è sta
scadendo il tempo non fatti due cazzo si
cagano sempre i piccioni dentro ma non
importa continuiamo vai e fai cos'è mai
così no mi scade il tempo ho preso bene
sono soddisfatto va bene così
non male vai così grazie mille mi sono
ripreso alla fine completato fortuna che
non ve lo mangiate voi
andiamo avanti ok raga stavolta direi di
andare sull'inglese che mi sembra amici
cos'è un budino a budino sin c'è scritto
anche cazzo scuote il telecomando wii
con delicatezza e cerca di rompere
l'uovo voi conoscete la mia delicatezza
mica faccio un disastro e la seconda
guerra mondiale manco hiroshima era così
disastrosa vai così rampi luogo come se
non ci fosse un domani sta cazzo
ebbene non riesco neanche a sbattere
l'uovo mica sono un genio come cazzo si
fa dai cazzo non ci riesco ok con la
tastiera non si riescono a rompere le
uova cazzo
devo avere il telecomando ma iniziò nel
muratore non funziona vai al meno uno ma
almeno uno rompino dai dai
neanche uno non sono riuscito a rompere
manco nuovo se che cazzo ti guardi così
la valtur prova c2 non parlo con la
tastiera e va beh ma tanto è uscita una
merda quindi gli se ne fotte quasi al
forno se cuociamo sto letame ci vuole
anche se devo anche controllare il forno
pure che devo fare devo prendere o fa il
momento giusto
ok ce l'ho fatta vai cos'è ce l'ho fatta
ho finito anche questo ragazzo non è
uscito così sarà uscita una roba del
tipo un uovo strapazzato un qualcosa del
genere però è pur sempre un budino
vabbè andiamo avanti manzo in salsa di
vino proprio quello che fa per me non
vedo l'ora di cucina rotaia e tagli a
pezzetti vai questo penso di riuscire a
farcela ce la posso fare
non è così difficile spalla cosa devo
fare la devo tagliare madonna ma non
meno neanche accorto c'è un coltello nei
della madonna non mi ero neanche accorto
che stava tagliando c'è potevo tagliarmi
un braccio praticamente mai così vai mio
dio
questo lo so fare non ci credo tra
l'altro la gastrite che musica c'è di
sottofondo c'è ma che cazzo
[Musica]
ma no a cazzo c'ero quasi non ci sono
riuscito a va bene va bene così
a furia di fare un remix di cookie ma ma
non sono riuscito a prendere il molto
bene ma non importa tipo loft o mio dio
vai così mi sembra di tagliare una mazza
da baseball vai vai vai che manca 16 il
fungo il fungo e piccolo ce la posso
fare sì che ce l'ho fatta fatto non ci
posso molto bene va bene così rai e
anche i piatti francesi mi vanno a genio
e cospargi cosparge di cosa di nutella
spero no cos'è cos'è sta roba devo adro
madonna devo girarli devo si è un po un
casino di giro a caso mai così vai così
voi cos'è
sono nato per impastare le cose vai
mamma mia da chi si è bloccato veramente
raga devo fare qualche provino per chi
avrà no non lo so io ho un talento che
non ho sfruttato mi sa se riesco se ce
l'ho fatta fatto sei perfetto sei molto
bene anche questo è il piatto che mi è
riuscito meglio di tutti che mi sta
riuscendo meglio di tutti aspettate la
fine se non brucio tutto spalma di burro
ok
proviamo a spalmare di burro semmai non
spalmata devo girare vai così o mio dio
cos'è la padella indemoniata anche
questa madonna
secondo me se lo facessi in cucina mia
tratterei tutto il muro o mio zio si sta
bruciando ok è diciamo che l'ho fatto
per metà padella un bene me lo regali
però quasi maledizione è impossibile
friggi in olio bollente ok
meno male che non ci metto le mani o
altrimenti mi brucia ray
c'è un ordine per mettere sta roba ma
noi mettiamo tutti insieme vai cos'è
ok giriamo a devo che spostarli forse no
ma non portarli a sì devo spostarli
cazzo che ne so io allora anche prima
dovevo farlo cioè prima sono riuscito a
prendere molto bene senza spostarli mica
un genio cazzo vai vai così vai i funghi
ancora non si sono bruciati no 16
bruciato cazzo ma male resti funghi di
merda bruciate vi cazzo non riescono a
cuocersi cuocetevi maledetti no dovete
cuocervi cazzo ma perché i figli non
maledizione ci sta bruciando sotto
lunghi di merda
siamo qui tutto il giorno finché non si
cuociono i fottuti funghi a cazzo ma dai
ma come cazzo è che non friggono i fondi
e fa si può ma dai
maledizione funghi di mer ma gli ho
messo non aveva messo i funghi porca
[ __ ] porca [ __ ] o bruciato tutto
alla fine ma si può ma che cazzo
unisci vai così tanto ormai andato tutto
a [ __ ] chi se ne fotte medio dai dai
no porca [ __ ] mix domizi vai gira gira
gira scrofa atta almeno questo ci provo
alto alto altro vice posta spostati
brutto stop no
che culo a caso vai unisci guarnizione
non è proprio quello che pensava ma vai
così passo passo passo ti prego dimmi
che riesco a se ti prego regalano molto
bene per riprendermi dapprima almeno va
bene facciamo che mi accontento buon
appetito ragazzi ricordatevi una cosa se
mai dovessi cucinare per voi per qualche
strano motivo
pensateci due volte prima di mangiare
vabbè raga io direi di chiudere qui
l'episodio è stato un qualcosa di
demenziale e tenete presente che queste
sono le prime ricette ovvero le più
semplici
aspettate le prossime e magari per la
prossima volta cerco di procurarmi anche
il telecomando così riesco a fare un
qualcosa di più decente così nella
webcam e vedrete che cercherò di girare
le padelle così non va bene sarà una
cosa memorabile credo però vabbè io per
questo episodio lo chiudo qui fatemi
sapere se volete che continui la serie
ovviamente lo vendono dai mi piace se
sono tanti continuerò la serie b di
ragazze mi è piaciuto video lasciate un
commento mi piace anche alla pagina di
facebook come non diviso trovate nella
descrizione se non siete ancora iscritti
iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo ad una
prossima ricetta bella ragazza